beyond the prosperous Emporium of
missouri's lies another Kingdom
belonging to King Pandey on there about
five hundred states distance from
Missouri's is the Emporium of Nell
kinder it is situated about 120 States
from the sea but it can be accessed by
River
however this river has sand banks and
shoals within its channels vessels
coming downriver from Nell kinder for
their outbound voyage must therefore
anchor in the open sea to take on board
their cargoes at the very mouth of this
river is another settlement called the
car a but the kings of Missouri sand
Nell kinder have their dwellings inland
from here vessels coming from the open
sea in the vicinity of these places will
get an indication that they are
approaching land as sea snakes will
emerge to meet them
these creatures are black in color but
they are shorter with dragon shaped
heads and blood-red eyes this video is
sponsored by audible the biggest
provider of audiobooks podcasts
meditation programs theatrical
performances and more with thousands of
titles and topics to choose from three
centuries worth in fact you can download
titles and listen to them offline and
you get one free credit to pick up a
title plus two audible originals every
month I've used my credit this month to
pick up the audio book version of RAL
McLaughlin's fascinating work the Roman
Empire and the silk routes a major
inspiration and source for the
east-meets-west videos that we do here
on voices of the past so if you like me
and many others I like to be able to
listen to a book while walking to work
or before you go to sleep or anytime
sign up for your free one-month trial at
audible.com slash V o TP
or text vo TP to 500 500
Thanks
ships in the port of missouri's and now
kinder carry full loads because of the
volume and quantity of pepper and
cinnamon that is available here they
offer us a market for mainly a gram of
money but also peridot limited
quantities of clothing with no
adornments multicolored textiles sulfide
of antimony coral raw glass copper tin
LED a limited quantity of wine but the
same as goes to Barry Gaza Emporium
grain in sufficient amounts for those
who are involved in the shipping
business because the local merchants do
not use it the export pepper grown for
the most part katana rek this is the
only place connected to these two trade
ports where pepper is grown we also
export good supplies of fine quality
pearls ivory Chinese silk cloth Gangetic
nard mullah brothel bought from the
interior and all kinds of transparent
gems diamonds and sapphires and
tortoiseshell the kind from the golden
land and also the kind called around the
islands lying off lime mary kay itself
in the past men used smaller vessels to
arrive here they followed the curves of
the bay from karna and you Dame on
Arabia the sail a whole coastal route
which has just been described then when
a ship's captain named hip hollows
plotted the location of the points of
trade he realized the configuration of
the sea and he was the first to discover
the route over open water in this place
the winds we call it easy on blow
seasonally from the direction of the sea
southwesterly breeze therefore makes his
appearance in the Indian Ocean this wind
is now cool after the name of the person
who first discovered the direct way
across even now because of this wind
some ships can leave directly from karna
and others from the promontory of spices
any vessels bound for limeira que can
hold out the wind in this quarter for
most of the way other ships that are
bound for Barrett Gaza and everyone
going to Sevilla keep the wind on this
quarter for only three days and no more
and this manner ships will be carried
away from the land over the ocean on the
high seas
they will bypass the previously
mentioned bays and can continue for the
rest of their run on their own proper
course
now beyond Bach RA
there comes the Red Mountain as it is
called with a region known as the
seaboard extending directly to the south
the first stopping place on the coast
that has a good Harbor is called bolita
after this the next stopping place is a
little settlement port called colmar it
is said that the one time a goddess
dwelt there and performed ablutions so
men who wished to have a holy life
perform cleansing rituals practice
celibacy and choose to remain there for
the rest of their days women also do the
same beyond Komar the region extends as
far as cold choy and it is here that
convicts dive for pearls the region is
under the king of pantheon after Col
Troy along the borders of a bay is an
area called The Strand in one place
pearls are gathered inland from here is
a region named our garu it exports
cotton garments vessels sailing for both
fly America and points north cool that
the following trade ports and harbors in
order of importance they are Kamara
but.okay and of so Padma these places
are home ports for the local boats that
sail along the coast as far as la mera
cake oversized
dugout canoes called sang Gaara held
together with a yoke dock here and the
same ports are used by the very large
Qalandia fonta that sail across to cry
sea and the Ganges region there is a
market in these places for all the
Western trade goods imported by lime
mira que
generally speaking goods are trafficked
all along this coast
all year round both the cash originated
from Egypt and most cards of goods
originating from and supplied by limeira
Kate regarding the regions beyond the
land of garu the course now turns off
towards the east projecting due west
into the ocean there was an island that
extends almost up to the part of a zania
that lies opposite nowadays it is called
Perl AC mundo but its inhabitants know
it by the ancient name of tapri Barney a
part of it uh lives towards the north is
civilized it produces pearls transparent
gemstones cotton garments and
tortoiseshell around this area lies the
region of masala which extends far
inland great many cotton garments and
produced there from this area
if you sell do you east across the bay
that lies alongside you will come to the
design country this is a habitat of a
kind of elephant called the bazaar a
beyond here the course now turns towards
the north here are numerous barbaric
peoples among them the Kira day a race
of wild men with flattened noses and
other people other Barga soy then there
are those called horse faces who are
said to be cannibals after this by
heading east with the ocean on the right
and saving on an hour course to the left
pass the remaining parts of the
coastline you will reach the Ganges
region and this vicinity Christ says the
furthest part of the mainland towards
the east there was a river nearby this
also called the Ganges this is the
greatest of all the rivers in India and
has a rise and fall like the Nile so
here are shipped out sinnamon Gangetic
nard pearls and cotton garments of the
very finest quality
he said that there are gold mines in the
area in the region as a gold coin called
the keltus beyond the river is an island
in the ocean is the furthest landmass
towards the east and is positioned
beneath the Rising Sun this land is
called crisi and it supplies the finest
tortoise shell of all the places in the
Indian Ocean at the Ganges region you
are by now at the northernmost point
somewhere on the outer fringe where the
sea ends there is a very great inland
city called thena
from this place silk floss yarn and
cloth a traffic by land by way of
Bactria to barek Gaza silk is also taken
by the Ganges River - limeira K it's not
easy to get to this thena only rarely do
people come from it and even then only a
few the area lies right under Earth's a
minor and it is said is connected to
parts of the pontus and the Caspian Sea
it lies on the same parallel as Lake
Mauritius and the junction where the
Caspian empties into the northern ocean
every year certain tribe called the
sesor tay turns up at the border their
lives between them and the people who
live on the thenar side the sesor type
people are short in body and have a a
level faced profile they come bearing
great packs resembling mats of green
leaves and bring their wives and
children with them then they remain at
some location on the border spread out
their mats under them and hold a
festival for several days after this
they return to the wrong in that homes
local people are expecting this so they
turn up in the area to collect all the
Saturday have spread out for
exchange what lies beyond this area
because of extremes of storm the bitter
cold and the difficult terrain but also
because of some divine power of the gods
these places have not been explored
[Music]